well as John mentioned earlier in the
show President Trump arrived here in
Singapore after leaving the g7 economic
summit in Canada and to say that he
shook things up there would be well an
understatement not long after the
president departed his top trade adviser
accused Canada of stabbing the u.s. in
the back
here's correspondent Ellison barber on
July 1st Canada says it will impose
roughly twelve point eight billion
dollars worth of retaliatory tariffs on
the US taxes on goods in two lists
variations of products made from steel
iron aluminum items many Americans have
at home yoghurt chocolate maple syrup
coffee whiskey's playing cards toilet
paper ballpoint pens I don't want to
hurt American workers they're our
neighbors they're our friends but my job
is to stand up for Canadian workers
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
says he does not want to impose the
tariffs but claims he has no choice the
administration's choice to impose
illegal and unacceptable tariffs
illegitimate and unacceptable tariffs to
Canadian steel workers and auto workers
and on the Canadian economy must be read
met with an equivalent response that
news conference enraged the president
and his administration they say Canada
has wronged the US on trade for years
that the u.s. is steel and aluminum
tariffs on Canada Mexico and the
European Union are a national security
necessity President Trump says the u.s.
is now looking at adding more tariffs
this time on automobile imports there's
a special place in the hell for any
foreign leader that engages in bad faith
diplomacy with President Donald J Trump
and then tries to stab him in the back
on the way out the door now I'll tell
you this to my friends in Canada that
was one of the worst political
miscalculations of a Canadian leader in
modern Canadian history one Republican
congressman says the president isn't
wrong when it comes to some of his
complaints on trade but he's concerned
about a trade war in my district I hear
from
farmers I hear from heavy equipment
manufacturers all of them have concerns
about tariffs specifically with Canada
he needs to be strong in getting a
better deal but making sure too that we
don't get into a full-fledged trade war
tariffs could possibly lead us there
there are also questions about what this
could mean for NAFTA talks US Secretary
of Commerce Wilbur Ross previously said
the talks were separate from tariffs but
on Saturday Canada's Finance Minister
reportedly said they cannot work on
NAFTA negotiations under the quote
threat of tariffs brett ellison thank
you